[Musik]
ich muss jetzt interviews geben und so
irgendwie ist alles anders
diego maradona ist offensichtlich 1 1 da
ein willst da ein großes produkt der
sportindustrie selbst hat eine tragische
figur traurigen figur ein hanswurst eine
zum teil auch verhasster mich dabei war
mein befreien
ehrlich gesagt ging es mir beim fußball
zuallererst nur um ein haus für meine lg
versenden mitgeflogen die kavalkade sich
dem stadion in neapel mehr und er wird
sozusagen gefühlt zur präsentation und
ständig sind die bodyguards dar
und allein das ist das motiv des
leitmotivs im grunde des films ein mann
der geführt wird betitelt gehalten
geschützt aber vielleicht auch an der
kandare ja der auch zum instrument
ich warne sie wenn sie noch mehr kommen
breche ich die pressekonferenz ab
und labbadia zeigt ein star in den
fängen der industrie die ihn umgibt
und dann macht er vielleicht mal 87n
jakl den titel klar für neapel in der
stadt die nie was gewonnen hat die von
den anderen bereichen nicht ergebnissen
clubs verarscht wird verspottet da ist
die afrikaner afrika ist die dreck
fressen
ich hatte den eindruck er heute vor
ihnen etwas weg laufen zeigt ihnen
nachdenklich er zeigt ihnen als einen
einsamen menschen der eigentlich auch
nicht mehr in der ablehnung der zahlt
einen hohen preis sind dankbar für
seinen hohen aber doch eigentlich ist
das leitmotiv diego gefunden habe ist
der arme junge der es aus dem nichts zum
raumschaft maradona ist der name des
markenprodukte mit yego gehe ich bis ans
ende der welt gekommen aber mit maradona
keinen schritt mehr über die jungs was
denn seine größe hatte ja auch immer
etwas vulgäres aus der gosse kommendes
das hat aber auch diesen apps für das
volk für die einfachen leute die zum
ersten mal da ein weltstar auf ihrem
niveau sahen sie anfassen konnten das
motiv des anfassen des anwachsens des
berührend des erreichens ist für den
film gangs
ich will nur maradona sein
man hat also hier in ein starkes pathos
im impfstoff es ist unendlich spannung
grandios konto
auf dass er immer seltener diego bad und
immer öfter maradona
[Musik]
die ganze umgebung der industrie fußball
industrie in dieser ausbeuterische welt
die ihn ausgezogen hat das macht doch
das sorgt dafür dass dieser film zwei
stunden sehr packendes kino ist obwohl
er vorgeblich nur in anführungszeichen
ein dokumentarfilm ist
ich will einfach nur madonna sein